yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and it's time to talk about the big
reveals in solo a Star Wars story and
what the film's ending means for Star
Wars an obi-wan kenobe movie and
possible solo sequels to celebrate the
release of a new Star Wars film I'm
running a Star Wars giveaway for all my
subscribers for a chance to win make
sure you're subscribed to my channel and
leave a comment below with your thoughts
about the movie spoilers ahead for the
solo movie so take care if you haven't
seen it yet let's start with the
surprise reveal of darth maul at the end
of the movie if you last saw him get
sliced in half by obi-wan Kenobi in the
Phantom Menace you might be wondering
how Maul is still alive
well the Sith Lord miraculously survived
Obi Wan's blow and drop into the reactor
shaft using the Force to pull himself
into an air vent where he fell into a
vat Maul ended up being transported to
another planet where he was eventually
rescued by his brother fans of the Clone
Wars and rebels animated TV series would
have seen him on the show where he
acquired robotic legs which you can also
see in the hologram of him in the solo
movie maul is a popular prequel villain
some fans have been hoping would return
in a live action movie and this brief
appearance at the end of solo could be
setting up the Sith Lord as a series big
bad who could span across multiple solo
and other anthology and prequel movies
and speaking to more was kira who he
commands to come to see him on Dathomir
where they will work more closely which
means we'll likely see emilia clarke
returning in any new movie with darth
maul by the way notice in this scene
that Darth Maul is wearing the same kind
of pendant we saw Kira WA earlier when
she saw Han in the cantina scene
it's a crimson dawn half logo necklace
we get to see a darker side of Kira and
her scene with Darth Maul what she seems
to have no trouble in lying to him
claiming it was Beckett who killed
Dryden boss when of course she did
and their numerous hints earlier in the
movie - about unspeakable things that
Kira's done as Beckett told Han at the
end of the film she's a survivor Kira's
part in solo ends with her piloting
dryden space yacht off to meet with more
but as she leaves she can see she's a
little conflicted looking out at Han on
the cliff top below the filmmakers have
said that Kira is probably the most
complex character in the film and there
are still things we need to learn about
her for example we don't know what Kira
had to do to get off Corellia or what
and during the three years that she and
Han were separated or how she rose up
the ranks of the crimson dawn so quickly
it's possible that she's compromised in
some way to Darth Maul and maybe she
thinks that she could put hands life in
danger if she goes with him characters
also seemed resigned to her fate saying
to Han earlier in the movie that it's
not about winning but how long you can
stay in the game and because she's a
prequel character who never appears or
as mentioned in the original trilogy
it's safe to say that Kyra probably
won't live beyond the future sequels by
the way there's a very cool musical
Easter egg in the mall and Keira scene
with some of John Williams jewel of the
fates playing in the background duel of
the fates as a musical theme that
Williams compose for the prequel trilogy
and it first played in the Phantom
Menace during the lightsaber battle
between Darth Maul qui-gon and obi-wan
so what could we see happen with Darth
Maul in a future movie well previously
in the Clone Wars more set of a criminal
organization called the shadow
collective in its heyday the collective
totaled five major criminal groups under
its alliance one of which was a Hutt
clan which had been forced to join the
Hutt's later abandoned the group and
there was a very big hint at the end of
solo that the big shot gangster they're
heading off to meet on Tatooine is Jabba
the Hutt meaning that a seat pool could
have Han and Chewie forced to go up
against more perhaps on behalf of Jabba
another member of Maul shadow collective
was the pike syndicate from one of that
gangs members also made a brief
appearance and Solo during the castle
scenes I also thought the placement of
Mandalorian armor and dried emboss is
study is a nod to the upcoming boba fett
anthology movie that logan director
james mangold is working on for
Lucasfilm now I do also think that
there's an alternative or additional
movie that Darth Maul and perhaps Kira
could appear in which is the heavily
rumored obi-wan Kenobi movie that a lot
of fans have been hoping for
interestingly Ewan McGregor appeared at
the solo premiere even giving interviews
obi-wan struck the seemingly lethal blow
to Darth Maul and episode 1 so the two
do have history but the potential
wrinkle is that much of this has been
explored in the Canon TV shows with the
two even facing off for one fateful
final jewel on Tatooine however not
everyone's familiar with the animated
series so we could see a live-action
recreation of that jewel in an Obi one
movie the movie might also change some
elements of
story which has already been told and
the TV shows although that could work
some fans but both Darth Maul and
obi-wan a hugely popular characters in
the fandom and if Lucasfilm sense as an
opportunity to capitalize on that I
suspect they'll take it I'm really
pleased to see that ray park returned as
Darth Maul Park played him in the
Phantom Menace and in solo Moore's voice
is provided by Sam Witwer whose voice
the villain in the animated shows park
seems like a really nice guy and when I
interviewed him before the new trilogy
kicked off this is what he said about
coming back to Star Wars
it really did Dan I'd love to come back
as Darth Maul that's what I want to do I
would do I would go crazy governmental
get locked myself from the cabin you
know do the whole method and two or
three months and you know spearfishing
and stuff and just to play the character
again the koalas next to the prequels
solo of course connects to the original
trilogy and the reveal of emphasis and
her card rider gang seems to be a nod to
the early days of the Rebel Alliance and
when Elvis ness says to Han you could
come with us we could use someone like
you it's an interesting parallel with
how Han our salute to go with him and
abandon the Rebel Alliance just before
the attack on the Death Star you come
with us pretty good in a fight good use
you come on why don't you take a look
around you know what's about to happen
what they're up against they could use a
good pilot like you you're turning your
back on it now Hank doesn't go with
enthis ness preferring instead to work
on a big score for someone like Jabba
the Hutt but like Kira said to Han
earlier you're the good guy and the solo
movie is planting the seed for hand to
eventually do the right thing because
Han did come back at the last minute
during the Death Star battle to save
Luke later in solo hand tracks down
Lando for a final bet to win the
Millennium Falcon when he meets Lando
they hug just like they do when they see
each other in the Empire Strikes Back
but Han who knew that Lando is cutie
when he played him earlier in the solo
movie uses a hug to steal the card that
Lando hidden up his sleeve which is how
Han eventually won the Millennium Falcon
and given that both Han and Lando
cheated and there's the BOK games it
brings an extra level of meaning to this
line from Empire what have you done to
my ship
hey remember you lost her to meat fair
and square the other important moment at
the end of solo is hands final
confrontation with Beckett over the
course of the movie we can detect
Beckett's cynical influence on Han
Beckett betrayed him to Dryden boss
telling Han earlier in the movie assume
everyone will betray you and you'll
never be disappointed and then of course
Keira did leave Han at the end to it his
standoff against Beckett Han doesn't
hesitate to shoot first demonstrating
he's internalized these skeptical views
about honor and betrayal and of course
reminding us of that scene with Greedo
and a new hope so what did you think of
solo and how does it compare with your
other favorite Star Wars movies and you
have any predictions on how Darth Maul
Kira or Han and Chewie could return in a
sequel make sure you're subscribed and
leave me a comment about the movie for a
chance to win a Star Wars Funko pop I'm
working on some more solo video so be
sure to ring the notification bell to
keep up to date with all my new uploads
and if you enjoyed this likes and shares
are always very much appreciated plus
you can check out more of my ending
explained and theories by tapping here
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers